two sheriff's shot point blank execution
style in california disturbing new video
shows a 31 year old deputy tending
to her partner who's 24 years old as she
hides
them both from uh uh behind a column
after a man fires a gun at the 2la
county sheriff deputies sitting in their
patrol cruiser saturday night in compton
reward money now 175 thousand dollars
los angeles mayor
eric garcetti on sunday condemned
protesters for reportedly yelling death
to police
outside the hospital where two los
angeles county sheriff police department
deputies
are being treated and in critical
condition after being shot have you seen
the video by the way
yeah kai have you seen the video if you
got the video to for for people if
they've not seen
it this is the visual okay just so you
know so they're in their
uh a car this this person that's walking
up
originally they had no plans of doing
anything
he's about to walk by then all of a
sudden he pulls out his gun and he
starts shooting
okay in the in the 20s the window is
open or no uh
i don't think this angle you it looks
like it's open but it may not be open
the the cop that they that the person
shot at got a 26 year old kid she's 24
years old she's hospitalized not in good
conditions
trump said if either one of them dies
if either one of these cops dies he says
this person is going to be
getting the death penalty and and uh you
know for for that to be taking place
then the local sheriff in la came out
and said
hey lebron since you really lives really
matter to you why don't you match the
175 000
of the donation that we got to lebron
this was just said last night so
what are your thoughts you're you're in
l.a right now what are your thoughts
about this uh it's so disturbing on
on multiple levels this is sick it's
it's unbelievable
it's very unsettling but i think almost
as bad as the fact that these protesters
get into the hospital here's a quote
according to the sheriff's department
the protesters were blocking the
entrance and exit of the hospital
emergency room and one of them was
yelling we hope they die
i mean here's the scary thing for me
this is so organized right for
protesters
to be on the spot to a know where the
hospital is to get down there
to be in front of the hospital to have
these types of chance er
there's a big thing brewing here that's
uh that's quite scary lebron's probably
not going to do anything i doubt if he's
going to match that
he probably would have done it right
away did you hear that the black lives
matters uh
blocked his butt blocked the lakers bus
yesterday and and there was
something going on in florida as well so
lebron seems to be in in the crosshairs
on both sides
trying to get his attention but look i
hope that i mean there's not much else
to say trump even took heat for saying
that how can that be a controversial
statement to say
that these guys need to be brought to
justice immediately and have a death
penalty you know
uh attached to the to the sentence but
you know you know what's my biggest
challenge with lebron by the way
i've been in u.s since november 20 1990.
what's special about november 20 in 1990
is that's the year where the finals were
lakers against the bulls so i watch
michael make that shot over sam perkins
where he goes up and he switches for no
reason and comes up left-handed
sam perkins was trying to block my shot
as if sam perkins with a six-inch
vertical leap can block
michael's shot right who was high most
of the time by the way i i
never see sam perkins play that guy's
he's got a good left-handed shot by the
way the three-pointer used to hit him
but but i've been a laker fan for 29 30
years now
it's the first year i'm now rooting for
the lakers you know why here's why
to me michael if there was a political
issue
he would say i'm giving a million
dollars to black university or black
college and i'm giving a million dollars
to charity of a police department or
sheriff and he would talk about how the
cops protected him so well throughout
his career right
there's nothing that's unifying about
lebron james the only thing unified
about
lebron james is anybody that agrees with
him that's it
you have to be a blm supporter for him
to unify
if you're not you won't hear anything
from him big difference when a guy
that's the face of the league
is treating the the politics that was
just purely one-sided yeah
and no if he says it's not my
responsibility it's not on me you're the
face of the league
you call yourself the king the king
dictates what direction the nba goes 100
and everything good and bad that's going
on with today's nba is because of the
king because you are the king
so i you know i i would love for him to
come out i'd love to be wrong
i'd love to be wrong yeah but i highly
doubt he's going to come out and support
the situation you know michael had the
great quote he goes republicans buy
shoes too so
he you know had business interests at
the forefront of most everything he did
as well michael was very savvy very
smart that's why he stayed neutral but
so does lebron
lebron's media company is doing very
very well
i mean he's spring kill yeah they're
gonna kill it by the way
yes they've come to hollywood and
they've they've been very very
successful so you would think
somebody like that would maybe want to
straddle the line a little bit more
because
personally i look at lebron as a social
activist that also plays basketball
i think it's the other way no i look at
his basketball as being secondary i
agree with you and it's so sad because
they're going to walk to the finals
probably
and they'll probably win it all i mean
the thing that's going to
i don't want to get all sports on you
but i mean the free throw shooting is
horrendous right so that could cost them
down the road but
he has a chance to to seize this mantle
of being the only guy to win three
championships with three different teams
and lead him
all the way and he's gonna blow it
because he's offending more people than
he's
generating uh excitement but but but the
thing i will give him credit for
i don't think he really cares yeah i
don't think he knows what he's doing
yeah i mean he's dropping f-bombs on
social media the whole thing
not not that he he knows what he's doing
i don't think he knows what he's doing
i think he knows who he wants to be and
he could care less
if he's losing half the audience or not
hey pat do you have a problem with that
though
i don't have if you know who you are and
you know what you want to be and you
stand for something
what's wrong with that yeah for me i get
it i like people that are willing to
like for example
do you remember when the jesse smallett
thing that took place
do you remember when that took place of
course do you remember the first time
they asked trump about it what trump
said
no do you remember what trump said to
the tune that he didn't believe it or
something no no
no no he believed in it that's right he
said
we gotta catch him this is not fair that
we gotta you know
justice needs to be served he defended
jesse smallett yeah
and there's no way in the world he would
support jesse smallett
right after finding out the story his
immediate reaction is to do what
support he's not like that so no matter
how how much people say that trump is
divisive
trump is not as divisive as lebron's
device hey i'll say one more thing i
think this nba bubble is putting these
guys
in a very weird environment you listen
to doc rivers comments i mean doc
stick to basketball right now no one
really is looking for you
to become a political activist and
that's all he seems to be doing as well
now but i think you're in a hotel room
maybe your wife's there but not your
kids some of your family
your your normal routine is out the
window you have 18 to 20 hours of down
time a day
all you have is your phone and social
media i think that's adding a little
fuel to it and it's gonna
you know go another month too if they
make the finals are you telling these
nba players they should shut up and
dribble i'm not saying that at all i
think that's what's going on i'm saying
the bubble is affecting them and i think
they're having more time
to not be around normal society where
you might have a little bit more open
mind about things so here's well
everyone's dealing with some sort of
you know covet bubble right now they're
literally dealing with the bubble but i
think everything is so amplified right
now
and i mean my biggest problem like just
for me
okay so if you don't if you don't find
what happened to the police officers
[ __ ] disgusting then you're on the
wrong side of the equation here ladies
and gentlemen like that is disgusting
so the people that for whatever reason
support that
you're hurting your cause here gentlemen
or ladies and gentlemen let's see if
lebron's tweeted about it i haven't even
checked i mean if i'm if he has tweeted
about it and saying something
especially it's his town it's his city
nope not one tweet not one tweet about
it he should
not one tweet about that so the biggest
problem i'm just gonna say one thing the
problem these days
is everything is so polarized it's this
or that
your blm or your your black lives matter
or your blue lives matter you're red or
you're blue
you're you're you're maggot or you're
blm it's why can't we all
just be a little bit of just about a few
comments here to respond for both of you
guys what you said one i don't mind
uh athletes being uh sharing their
opinions if it's sincere like for
example
cap he knelt and he says here's what
this is well there was a lot of you know
a hypocrisy behind his movement that
what he did mom's you know
white he's half white and you know then
he wears the pig
socks while he's playing in miami i mean
look now you're playing with fire you're
talking about
people that escaped castro so you know
but ali
when ali did it ali also got along with
everybody on both sides ali was still
likeable when him and you know they were
going at it with a couple different
people
i don't have i don't he was actually you
would be his biggest
enemy when they would do interviews he
would he would always stand up
but at the same time he was partying
with everybody
you know ali was good with everybody ali
wasn't just one-sided guy when you read
the stories about it if you go to his
museum in kentucky louisville if you've
never been
highly recommended we're doing an event
there actually sapalas and vargas and
delways and kahindi and
my mission mason they're doing an event
there in january which i'm looking
forward to going to because i love the
ali museum this is what i will say about
this part here
this whole message is not about lebron
it's not about daca reverse it's about
these two sheriffs
my concern is the following here's my
biggest concern um
yesterday we're having a meeting here
okay and
one of my sales reps asked me a question
and says
what do you say when the person says
this
okay and i said what do you mean so what
do you say if the person says this and
they say if you don't do this i won't do
this
i said the reason why this person is
saying this is because they
feel comfortable being able to say that
to you what do i mean by that
you know how you sit with somebody and
somebody says shut up you know
and you don't like it you know how
people say shut up you know it's it's
not like a
uh a bad thing to say don't you say shut
up
i had a girl i worked with we're good
till today
she's won the best right now what we do
with the business she had a tendency of
saying this very quickly to everybody
and so one day she said it to me i said
can i whisper something to you just you
and i she said yes i said have i ever
told you to shut up
she said never i said please don't say
to me either. i don't like the
terminology shut up
just don't say it to me she says uh i'm
so sorry so no you don't have to
apologize
it's very normal i actually don't think
you have anything negative to say about
it but moving forward
i'm not gonna say shut up you don't need
to say shut up let's have that mutual
respect for one another
she said okay so the next time you know
we're saying something just like oh
show. i'm so sorry i said no just the
fact that you caught yourself guess what
i respect the fact that you're
respecting me let me tell you what's
going on here what the bigger concern is
people are thinking it's okay to shoot
cops right now and that's a byproduct of
politics
people in california think it's okay to
shoot cops right now so as much as
garcetti is coming out and saying this
stuff
you are indirectly making people think
that they are doing something good to go
after cops because it's a way of getting
their 15 seconds of fame and they're
going to be talked about and oh my gosh
blm is going to say oh phenomenal let's
go defund the police all this other
stuff
you have to be very careful what you
recognize for if you tell your kid
kid great job there's this book that was
on parenting he said
the the author of this book says
whatever you recognize your kids for and
give attention for
they're going to keep doing it meaning
if the kid is sick you only hug your
kids and tell them you love them when
they're ki
they're sick they're going to keep
telling you they're sick you got to hug
and kiss your kids
when they're doing okay you got to do
good to them when nothing's going on
but if you recognize them and you laugh
at them saying a stupid joke to somebody
and you think it's funny using
bad words they're going to keep doing it
because it's a form of recognition
california is indirectly promoting
these types of behavior and it starts
with newsome and it starts with garcetti
and all that stuff needs to be stopped
by the way
shout out to newsom because newsom did
send a tweet out
and one of the things i like about what
newsome did the last 24 hours you guys
know how i am about newsome if he does
stuff
i'll call him up but i got to give him
respect as well and i know some of the
people that are watching the same path
i cannot believe you're going to say
this about newsome let me tell you what
at least he did
and whether you say it's good or not
here's what he did do yesterday
he got up there and he says a 31 year
old mother and a 24 year old are
fighting for their lives because of this
cowardly horrific act
the perpetrator must be quickly brought
to justice praying for a full recovery
for the deputies
and then she has the name and his wife
and him are praying
and are keeping their loved ones and
their thoughts listen and he did that
immediately
restricted good freak no i'm giving you
something he's the governor he should
whatever yes i know you're giving him
but what i'm saying is and then on top
of that let me tell you what he did
yesterday
the fires are going on in california
yeah trump flies in to meet with him
he doesn't say pulling off a publicity
stunt i will never meet with him if he
comes in he says no
let's sit down newsome sat right here
while trump sat right here and trump was
being briefed on what's going on in
california
and trump was listening to everybody and
news i'm sitting here now think about
how uncomfortable he is
his ex-wife is dating his son let me say
this one more time
governor newsome's ex-wife is dating
his son and he still has the audacity to
sit right
next to trump i respect i know what his
positions are
i know where he's at with this but i
respect the fact that he's willing to do
this
you cannot by the way i hope he's
realizing you cannot go out there and
say
you cannot show up to church oh but you
can go out there and protest and you
cannot do that
this hypocrisy needs to stop at the top
because these guys are thinking it's
okay
and i hope this is the last shooting
towards sheriffs and cops
but unfortunately if i'm a betting man
in vegas i'm telling you i don't think
celeste
well especially not next two months